what is up everyone happy friday happy
call of duty beta day i'm david ahmadi
i'm gonna be your host i'm joined with a
bunch of gamespot folks here and we are
ready to dive in to call of duty modern
warfare 2's beta uh right now it's gonna
be mostly team death match with some
like locked loadouts but we messed
around a couple of minutes before the
stream started and it's looking really
good so everyone in discord say what's
up say hi to chat we are live on youtube
and twitch
how's it going
let's all yell at the same time yeah
you guys might recognize a few of these
voices i got aaron uh aaron in the chat
i've got jake and i've got tom who you
probably see all the time on gs news
telling you about uh modern warfare 2
and everything you guys should be
looking forward to so guys let me just
pop us right into quick play and we're
going to get started now tom and jake
are also going to be checking out chat
so if you guys have any questions or you
guys want to just give them some shout
outs or share some love feel free to do
so
someone in the chat team cb says it
feels like battlefield 2042 now is that
2014 launched or 20 yeah
there's you know yeah
yeah we want we want some uh we want a
bit of a distinction there right
need some clarity on that please yeah
yeah there's validity in like modern
warfare being a sandbox at least but
yeah if you're talking about brokenness
well this is of beta so yeah
beta's our betas i know that they kind
of come across as demos these days and
we'll see if they have time to change
anything in this game but we played a
couple rounds so far it's been pretty
pretty like solid
it's got that like weighty movement good
recoil on guns yeah we'll see what how
like the dolphin diving stuff plays out
over time there's the water the water
fights amphibious assaults and all that
um
i'm curious so out of our group here
which one of you guys are kind of feel
more comfortable with controller and
that's like how you mostly play your fps
games i think it's aaron and jake right
you guys are the the call of duty
controller
i mostly play with controller however i
have never played a call of duty game on
playstation
i miss my xbox controller obviously
i just feel foreign
so it looks like we have three loadouts
here assault phantom and hunter which is
interesting
we should also disclose that we were all
totally [ __ ] talking how
like pros are playing in the stream
yesterday that it doesn't even look fun
to play that way yeah just playing like
people who play with controllers
we play this way to like enjoy ourselves
yeah
very chill
chill streak
the chat regarding like access and stuff
it is currently uh
hidden behind a paywall like pre-order
if you're on the playstation the open
beta fully from playstation
but i think like people are like giving
out codes and stuff like that
in the past so that might be a way for
you guys to jump in if you haven't
xfinity uh owners are able to customize
that's right yeah yeah there's like they
get to if you have comcast you get to uh
uh mess around with the beta
oh okay that car blew up in front of me
all right we got b and c
i say we play it pretty conservative
here yeah yeah yeah that's the
battlefield battlefield you don't need
to take all three whoop sniper
um
it's okay i'll just pretend you didn't
shoot me tom
that's true that's true we're never even
now
is there support for 120 hertz yes there
is i think they've supported that since
uh a black ops cold war since the new
generation
if you can lower the game a touch david
i don't know if you saw that i
absolutely can
oh
oh cool so check this out i'm spotting
for you guys but there's like a sniper
back here who's in a real summer beach
watch out for the guy over here he's
just holding it down quickly
goodbye aarons
the guy just quick scout me that guy
hit the quickscope
so far like it's been um
you can already tell from
what's here so far there's a lot of
sandbox to it which is very cool
and uh it's very infinity ward in the
sense that there's a lot of over under
routes we haven't even figured out how
to hang yet we're still trying to figure
that out the legend
the legend
word 789
says is it true terminal is on the way
um i don't know about um a dedicated
modern warfare 2 map but terminal is a
part of the larger
new warfare
so it's a part of that
but maybe they'll bring it to
to the monomorphic to multiplayer
all right they are probably getting
dangerously close to b we're losing b
pop the grenade in there oh i didn't
change my field of view
all right i cleared it i am
oh behind you jake there's clearing the
objective and the hallway yeah like
behind you in the left corner maybe okay
yeah yeah i see you see gunshots
oh i'm making fools now that i
pushed my field of view up to 120. yes
oh feel the view
yep
completely forgot
i'm on a ps4
i just
i took three steps and got cruise
missile
let's see if i can do that on ps4 pro
i don't want to drill charge that guy so
bad
so the drill charge goes through walls
it's very much like what fuse from
rainbow six
and i'm i'm finding that it actually
works on just regular cover too
keep fighting dang
oh oh man
all right i messed with my gun
and it is not good
i'm not doing well
you just left the default
you know being able to build a bad gun
is is good in my book oh my okay that
was a lot of people it means the game's
giving you enough room to like you know
mess up which means that
it uh it's cool that's a good system all
right i'm moving into b
we're gonna watch out for about there's
like a
balcony over b
yeah that's that that scares me
all right b is secure oh uh there's yeah
people in the hallway
jacob gonzalez what map is this what is
the name of this man
uh yeah mercado los alamos
almost yeah
that drug map it is a drone
i like this map i think this is a pretty
good map there's one map that um like a
museum map that i do not care for but
this isn't good losing sea
yeah it has good over underwraps that's
what i love about infinity ward maps is
you can learn to
navigate them with skill
i don't know what that is
kind of what i didn't like as much about
cold wars i thought those maps didn't
have these like really clever routes in
them which is very like you know three
lanes straight forward a lot of call of
duty players like yeah they are taking c
but i spawn near a so i guess i'm gonna
oh no they're not taking c anymore yeah
okay so just hold them
see if we can just hold them
oh one of our guys say okay i did that
or i've disconnected
clambering and then there's hanging but
we haven't figured oh
how to do that yeah you just you just
got killed by a um a bomb drone is that
i know
i did not get killed by the bombing
maybe me
you can also immediately just toggle the
score streaks for people who like this
over in the corner
damn this
this right lane over here gets is like
really contested
hold on to c and b
um we can probably get around and get a
in that case
i'm already like halfway to see right
now
wow oh quick scoper on c watch out
you can spot did you i don't think you
could spot modern warfare too
sorry modern warfare
definitely not the original modern world
yeah i mean sorry i mean 2019 yeah yeah
uh i think that quickscoper just got
nuked so
she's good
everyone really want to drill
one on b
we have someone asking about time to
kill um
how are you guys feeling about that
quickly
yeah that's pretty sad yeah it feels no
i'm not used to it
oh where the hell that guy come from
doesn't feel too short
we're still in good shape but we gotta
we gotta i'm on it
oh damn
[Applause]
oh there's three people right in that
hallway yeah
i should have dolphin dived in there
but i think i just stopped a grenade
with it
all right maybe it's like an
interference thing it sounds like that
we're gonna have to test that if ddos
can stop a grenade that's being thrown
at you
oh
good
so we got this whole multiplayer launch
and then we got warzone after that
warzone sounds like it's also gonna be a
lot more complex like um there's bots in
warzone
just strongholds
oh you're trying to flank us aren't you
okay i was coming that was the head of
uav i'm not playing with a sound and
that's uh
rough oh no i
i'll say this for people asking in the
chat um about like fidelity and stuff i
think the game looks like that but
the guns feel
this one's got a little too much kick
for me for some reason i'm like not used
to it yeah gg
i love it i'm sick i'm sick of that
arcadey feel that we had in black ops
and i didn't play a lot of vanguard to
be fair so i don't know if that one
vanguard was like half an hour no one
played a lot of event guys yeah yeah
vanguard falls under the category of
games that is like totally adequate it
just kind of like it wasn't bad at all
it just tried to please both call of
duty audiences and wound up somewhere in
the middle where nobody was
like super pleased but right right
someone in chat
someone just says how to stream from ps5
and have
sound both on stream and headset
boy is that something that takes a lot
of uh practice to get
you can do a pass-through is the answer
to the pc
yeah i could have done it i just didn't
feel like i was like whatever it'll be
it'll be okay
no one's gonna see my game play anyway
so you can turn up the view in ps4 pro
also
oh that is right i wanted to see if i
could uh change the
frame rate
auto musician says the visual recoil
looks pretty harsh i'm i'm kind of with
you on that i mean granted i only messed
with the the locked assault class i'm
sure you know when we get our hands on
more uh
more weapons and in crafting and the
gunsmith 2.0 and all that it'll be
better but yeah i'm messing with the m4
and it is a little bit unwieldy than
what i'm used to
when you unlock it at level four let's
go have a look at it
yeah for
sure yeah i would say the visual recoil
is um
oh no what should i do
you probably just unlocked it
yep i just i just that's what happened
oh yes i'm excited to play this map this
one looks cool oh
this is the one i don't like
oh really
i mean you might you might you know it's
just
this is the one where
david what we're saying with battlefield
4 it just looked like a janitor's had a
fight on the map with how queen it was
oh yeah
just so cool
and
autumn warfare tends to be pretty dirty
in style usually so it's a little bit
weird to fight on a super clean map in a
modern warfare game right i think that's
probably my issue with it is just it
looks too
but you know outside
are you marked it
okay
ah being able to spot is so good
you can change it
oh that's how you do it sweet
oh he's behind us
no
uh so jake we can think down like in
like in warzone you can ping guns on the
ground so if you run out of ammo you can
have your
teammate all right i found ammo and by
found ammo i died
oh i got zapped
we found it
oh they're up top
yeah yeah i'm about to
oh my god shooting single fire
with this haptic
is difficult
so i can turn the haptics off huh
oh that's right uh the
ps5 has the
what adaptive triggers yeah yeah but
also like the haptic rumble too like
wow there's so many dead people in this
hallway guys i'd just like to tell y'all
how many
yeah
i
killed quite a few in this hallway seems
to be a good place to wait for him
[Laughter]
i've
oh yeah jesus
just took drugs guys i hit it i hit both
bumpers and i took drugs
but would also like you to know that
are you coming up what are you doing no
i'm just going to like
back to the map
but they're all right here i marked it
all of them are right here oh
nope
he dolphin dived
the um
i was just gonna say this the first time
i've ever heard that
the the thing that i absolutely love
about that tom is when i told you about
dolphin diving the first time you're
like does that think you're doing water
well i thought because the game now has
uh that you can swim and stuff so like
right
right
behind you
sliding so sliding i think you sprint
and tap circle to dive you sprint and
hold circles
i believe
yeah i just tried it
i'm more of a fan of sliding because
we can't fly over
here
yes there is
uh
i got battle rage i can take drugs
that's a good shout out to people in the
chat telling me i suck
at this time
uh
are you asking how many people are
because honestly not too many no no no
no i'm saying i'm i'm saying i'm saying
this is a shadow because i just hit a
five kill streak that's what ah there
you go i'm i'm dedicating it to them
this is what i'm doing oh okay
i'm fighting with each other chad what
are you all fighting over
they're fighting over whether this looks
the same as every previous call of duty
and uh is it worth spending their money
uh okay so a big catch on that it
depends what you're coming to modern
warfare four so the
winter preview event before we saw more
of this stuff but the core 6v6 maps
are probably a little bit smaller
and the
battle maps are bigger
so if you want the battlefield kind of
experience i was just in the menus
there's like a ton of tanks a ton of
vehicles
but the bigger experience is bigger and
the smaller experience is a little bit
smaller and i think just depends on what
you want
if you're looking for the sandbox this
game
[Music]
will probably have it once they start
getting those
battle maps out yeah
that's what this cruise missile looks
like
yeah i like this map i'm i'm gonna be
the dissenter in the group here
but i think i'm kind of more oh we both
but i've always kind of been a fan of
like the cleaner like
oh
this paddle is taking place in somewhere
you know what i mean yeah
it's always fun
you're into the janitor fight maps yeah
big time
if it looks like a janitor has been
through here in the last 24 hours i'm
all for it
oh someone just got
ripped to shreds yeah they did it let's
do this again
oh god electrocuted here you go dolphin
dive
that's what it looks like
go to your best flipper watch out in
that death hallway they put some
landmines there so if you find yourself
running through there
sometimes call of duty feels like that
meme where it's like the people sat in
the church and each one has a gun
behind
you got a bunch of battlefield people
here too and that is the forever
battlefield problems that game is mostly
about getting shot in the back
yep it's better
i guess that's what i eat absolutely
getting shot in the back
yeah i said i said um
i said um when i saw that
i tweeted out like battlefield 20 42 is
such an accurate military simulator like
hours of boredom and then you just die
without even knowing
why
it is a getting shot in the back
simulator
often
even for people who love it it is
yeah
when it's good though when you get into
the group of that game it's unlike
another one
but it
it really requires a lot of dedication
ah
i got shot in the back
hold up
all right no playing
[Laughter]
battlefield aaron i'm on you right now
okay
man it is pretty cool i just like swap
barrels on the fly and now it feels like
i'm using a different weapon like
what do you mean on the wall behind us
uh you can you can gunsmith like any
time in a match it doesn't look as slick
but uh there's like a little menu that
pops up and lets you
swap things out how do you do that
i mean you have to die it's like if you
go to your loadouts yeah it's not like
battlefield 2042 where you could add
[ __ ] i guess i will clarify
a crisis thing like it's weird how
only crisis lets you swap weapons in
game for
like a decade
to be fair i don't like it
i i like how i like switching in game
and then changing on death fine but like
it's a little cheesy when they hold up
the gun and then attachments start
popping in oh yeah
i realize i'm kind of in the minority
where it's like i want these to be like
realistic you know as realistic as the
game can be and
when someone's just out there getting
out their gun it's like all right
i mean have you ever have you ever been
out there on the battlefield jake that's
how
yeah
maybe so
it's schrodinger's uh gunsmith
until you know for real
i saw that
yeah i got stuck with one
oh i got blinded
i do i mean the attention to detail in
this
oh i just got assassinated holy [ __ ]
like seeing the bullets like continue to
fly off in the distance
um
after i've like missed someone is like
pretty like ridiculous
you guys managed to sneak up on someone
melee them in the back i think you do
have an executioner animation
i gotta hold it i think right yeah
otherwise you just go regular
probably it works the same man yeah yeah
for winning don't die that's a dub for
us though nice
all right let's go through the chat here
see if people have some questions
oh
jake got the last kill nice
oh that 2 1 kd i'll take it
people are saying uh people asking how
um
uh how recall like a lot of people are
saying like recall doesn't look so bad
some people saying like recall looks bad
like how are we feeling about
the recoil i personally like it i like
that um
messing with your with gunsmith and
changing your gun like dramatically can
change the recoil i think that's a neat
touch
uh it's obviously like if you're into
the more arcadey side of call of duty
you might not enjoy that aspect but i'm
sure
you know you could probably get an smg
and find a way to make it so it feels
pretty pretty tight yeah
damn i don't know
a crap ton of uh
unlike the crap ton of attachments just
now
yeah you need attachments pretty
generally
or generously
if you flip to the mini suit david you
can show people the um so perks are like
in packages now so you you earn perks
like killstreaks
uh
just the actual perk system so like
overkill and things like that oh gotcha
almost like how the special system
worked but all the time
in this game
i'm with jake here though like
again i think you come to modern warfare
or the more milsim slower pace like
less friendly guns that you have to sort
of wrestle into what you want them to be
and that's the fun part like they're not
arcady
you can't just laser people usually
how's this map
i like this map i think it's got a bad
name farm 18 like come on
like at least at least name it foundry
like every other uh shooter you know has
you gotta have a map called foundry
[Laughter]
the digital foundry
there you
every go i hear that i just think i'm a
lead farmer
right now
yo b is gnarly there are so many open
ways
yup to get here and just mess someone up
well that is freaking hilarious i just
shock charged myself and my guy
locked up on the trigger and just kept
shooting
[Laughter]
it's like you tasering yourself and put
your fingers on yeah already
oh that's a cool touch
i don't always shock charge but when i
do it
someone mantled up to the
roof and i got them what's this
oh camera says long seat
damn
so you can have a camera system i am
very skeptical that's like um like a
call of duty thing
oh i think we're actually going to use
it
they're probably going to take c again
okay
let's see
oh
oh
yeah that corner is a death trap don't
go there
let's meet up on 8th
a guy gaming asks is third person in
every mode we haven't actually played
any third person yet but i'm sure we
will get to
you guys but i think it is i think it is
available for everything
thank
uh
you
i feel like
c might be i'm on b like b
right now
oh no
not for long
i see someone running in there
i feel like what can be mantled from
what like yeah
it's weird because call of duty always
has that thing or it's like technically
i should be able to jump on to this but
the designers have decided that i can't
go here in this map
but this same box i can't get up so it's
kind of weird with the mantling where
it's like
like can i hang on this or can i not
hang on this because technically i can't
be here like uh right
seems like a
hole where they were way worse at that
um they would like put a barrel in a
corner so you couldn't like get into a
corner of a room or something like that
yeah
so in the scheme of things this is
actually pretty friendly
we all want to go
i'm going to move to c
i'm like right there and it's undefended
right now i'm
i'm trying to take back to you you got
someone on there
i just got shot from every which way
oh you can throw a camera and then you
look through it or something i don't
know i'm trying to figure out how this
camera works so you can look through the
camera
i ran into the bee shot them up
just activated my perk and i got
murdered
you guys are on the roof nice
yep
i am i don't know if it's probably a
good idea oh
i fell through a hole
i
not sold on this camera thing
what else we got here
from trophy system
playable cover
ah
man
five fifi says thank you for not jumping
into every doorway playing obnoxiously
or screaming
it's like
hell yeah do you have any questions hit
us up too like we're uh i saw a preview
of this game and then there's a massive
stream yesterday where we learned a ton
and we also all hate
preston miller says is there ground war
there isn't the final game but i don't
think this one of the beta has it right
yeah i know they did say they did say in
a fact sheet they sent us that there
would be ground war and we get one so
okay great
depending on what you're coming to
modern warfare for i think brown war is
kind of
it kind of like the the thing that
attracted a lot of people originally
yeah yeah
it's funny because i rarely played like
any ground war when i uh
these guys are just
jumping around no scoping me
so currently the people that can access
this beta are those that pre-ordered
or
um
people that have received codes
from either call of duty or a streamer
has given them away or
comcast
yeah xfinity
if you have xfinity you can get a free
beta code
that's so random i love it
but next weekend will be full of open
veda i'm getting
a playstation and then the weekend after
that
it is a pre-order beta for the consoles
and
xbox and pc and then the weekend after
that
is an open database
the top thing is that you've put up with
xfinity for enough years
they're like here you go we give you
three extra days of call of duty
requesting
but if you have an xbox just screwed
jake just had to switch away from sonic
which is like a premium
out here i don't know what happened
there but usually it's like
sucked it was like i was paying for uh
fiber and i was getting 80 megabytes a
second even when i was like right next
to the
um the router next to the router so i
switched to a tnt the other day and now
it's like 800 a second like that that's
that's what i want it's a little more
expensive but oh it's worth it
what's the one that all the people in
the east coast get totally abused by is
like adelphia or something like that
that sounds about right
we well i have i have verizon here in
new york
objective oh yeah just like pull on the
internet now
holy um
yeah uh chagon says there's no sliding
anymore there is actually if you run and
tap circle you will slide and if you run
and hold circle you will do a dolphin
dive which i love
i'm also learning today that a dolphin
dive has nothing to do with water yeah
you can dive on land ladies and
gentlemen
you do not need to be a dolphin
oh there is a it was confusing because
there is a lot of water in this game
just wait just wait until uh just wait
until they add adults
in this game
how do you activate a third person
by the way i think it's i think it's a
game mode i don't think it's a game mode
okay yeah dang we got worked on that one
yeah we did yeah that was rough
that was brutal
the good bad and ugly so far the only
ugly we found i think is like
menu systems hella confusing that might
be fixed before the end but it's all the
weirdly bad
yeah
and so far are oh if you flip through
the menus there's so many vehicles
there's like three or four different
kinds of tanks that's why i'm excited
for ground
the vehicles have pretty cool uh they've
got like enhanced destruction now too
like you can pop out tires the [ __ ] with
their handling a little bit and it's i
don't know it's pretty cool
i got kicked i just rejoined but i got
okay
that's the only thing that's available
to us
yeah there's some specific modes we can
do i think right oh yeah
here let me oh yeah we've got prisoner
rescue knockout knockout you guys want
to give one of those a try
yeah let's go for it
all right dealer's choice oh jinx dude i
said it nice
um
okay let me just close my eyes and pick
one
looks like it's prisoner squeeze
oh my god it keeps kicking me out of the
weapons
editing oh yeah anytime you're trying to
do anything like it's settings or
anything if
dave makes a uh does anything it kicks
you out really like like oh that's
that's messed up here well i'm gonna i'm
gonna look at this loadout real quick so
you guys feel free to mess with your uh
weapons for your second
i want to see look at this
vedic goyal says what are the main
differences between warzone 2.0 and
warzone this is a great time for me to
plug gamespot tick tock where i have an
explainer
hell yeah
um explaining all the differences some
of the highlights being uh
there are things called strongholds uh
so there are kind of like ai like areas
that uh are pve where you can get some
high level loot
uh you can do go swimming uh um uh and
what was one of the other ones oh the
gulag has like completely been changed
there's some really interesting changes
to the good luck so make sure if you're
not following it to go over to
tick tock game spot gamespot's tick tock
uh and check it out there hell yeah
vedic goyal says tick-tock is banned in
india though well i'm sorry
i'm sorry
the
call of duty not bans though
i don't know why that that was so funny
i wasn't expecting that
uh xbox will get beta access i'm just
not sure when when uh so xbox beta
access is in two weekends from now uh
for people that pre-ordered
three weekends from now for people that
uh
uh waiting for the open beta
uh let's
so like it's pretty cool i was watching
the stream like yesterday and they
started talking more about the gulag
so it's
it's it's gunfight now it's like 2v2 in
the gulag instead of 1v1 but there's a
jailer that shows up the jailers ai
and if both teams agree to work together
i don't know how you agree to work
together but if you do
you have to both work together to take
down the jailer and then all of you can
come back
which was really interesting well we'll
see how we'll see how often it works out
that way
what is the what is going to be the
gentleman's agreement
gentle person's agreement for not
shooting each other in the gulag it's
like uh everybody just tea bags or or
like
i don't know what it's going to be i
don't know i think it's just like do you
see the jailer first like it's gonna be
a case of like the do you see the jailer
first or the other opponents first i
think that's gonna really dictate
how that goes
so yeah if you you know when that
happens if you see the jailer don't i
guess don't shoot the other team and
hope they don't shoot you
i'm messing with some of these uh
these perks they look really cool
yeah oh yeah i should probably do some
customization
there's the perk package or whatever
yes it's like specialist oh here we go
progression it's like specialist in the
previous game so whenever you flip over
to special so you get you get the best
of both worlds now and in modern warfare
2 as opposed to one
you kind of get the specialist system
but you also still get the kill streak
so you don't have to choose one or the
other you get both at the same time
which is kind of cool
nice
uh
all right so i got my perk package
uh that's my fuel deck
a random thought but um
for vehicles i think david you mentioned
this i swear the stream what they said
was their vehicles will get rocked
differently depending on how like heavy
they are by different rpgs which is a
really cool touch nice it said it
sounded like the the actual movement a
vehicle would take by getting hit
will feel different depending on how big
the vehicle is so it's like
auto warfare the last one was just so
good at these uh like
attention to detail kind of things yeah
it seems like they're getting that in
this game too
if you guys are good i'll uh i'll load
us in
before let's do it
let's go
would you mess with your fov as well uh
tom is just like normal settings
yeah h yeah it should be like on the
graphics or
uh
yeah
feel the view yeah there we go
well same
one thing i'm a little concerned about
is the samurai package they've already
announced for playstation
yeah i don't know we're talking about
this but i do not want wacky skins in
modern warfare 2 this early you know
warzone broke off
warzone 2.0 broke off from the main war
zone and i think it's nice because we
didn't have like
not getting get killed and killed by
godzilla on day one
just
ah it's a level of silliness that always
happens with later in call of duty games
but it'd be nice to not have it right
leo virus in the chat brings up the good
oh i crashed
oh no
let me uh
load back in
should we leave the match
uh yeah yeah so we can all load in
together
there we go
the other team's gonna be happy they
just won yeah
[Laughter]
uh someone in chat who was it uh
leo novaras brings up the ui is more
mobilish
maybe that's why we're kind of not
vibing with it yeah maybe like it might
it does seem like it might actually be
more like touch they want more um
synergy with cod mobile maybe
i mean it would make sense right that's
a huge thing that we're talking about
next is like how they're trying to
create even if the experience and like
the actual like content and there's no
cross play between mobile and
yeah uh desktop and um
console
but if that if they're developing all
the tools at the same time you've got to
imagine it probably helps to design
similar interfaces uh ignore that uh
invite i think aaron i don't know if
that was like a party invite or just a
game invite
because i don't use playstation but oh
okay
yeah i think we're all on you all right
perfect i
i don't know jake were you saying like
in the stream is it was really kind of
funny and also i feel bad for those guys
but the all the mobile streamers who are
streaming
they had a hard time showing them
they're just basically like showing
their forehead and their videos
they did not plan well i gotta say we
threw on a mobile showcase uh i mean
granted there there's probably a a tad
more going into the call of duty one but
ours went a lot smoother than theirs did
and that was like five people
working on it compared to one of the
biggest companies on the planet
um
martos ranieri del jesus says why ps5 i
don't care about ps4 please play an xbox
series x i mean we all wish we had a
sweet xbox control in our hands but
beta is only on
playstation currently
yeah as of right now yeah
for this bit for this weekend yeah
actually
a lot of us fired up our playstations
for the first time in a while and
i was hoping that this ps4 pro wouldn't
go into full hovercraft mode because oh
my god with warzone
like it literally used to turn heads in
the office how loud this ps4 would get
it was crazy i was like
playing on ps4 pro right now
and uh how is it sounding right now
we did discover that the ps4 pro though
also has field of view slider which is
awesome so i guess
just like everywhere now
let's come up with a plan here because
this is let's go that revives but let's
go
yeah
all right
david i think you're gonna have to call
to call the shots because we got to work
as a team on this one
for sure i'm not gonna get used to this
dolphin jump yeah all right i'm uh
moving over towards the left prisoner
oh you got shots oh nice
putting the door
be there
oh he got me
can i res you yeah
let me know
there is rest getting rez
this is very siege
the moment that i saw 4v5 remaining i
was like oh my god
he's this guy's reviving some of us
yeah grab the hostage grab the hostage
and go if you can
right crap
detection will revive
all right
yes stick with them
yep we're with them
looking behind us
oh we got a teammate we could revive uh
[Music]
i think they just revived their guys so
we're in a 3v4 now yeah
have i read that right
got one
you stay together
oh he's in he's in the fountain okay
or is he dead
oh behind us behind us yep
it's got taken out
no way we're at
uh like oh lord oh
[ __ ] stabbed
i guess like points wise we did is it
because we
yeah i think you get like a hundred
points for rescuing but if you clear the
other team
you get 50.
okay
we made bad decisions
[Laughter]
oh it's cool the kill cam's like a it's
like a gopro yeah it
is we're all watching your gopro
[Laughter]
no crash no crash
gopro died i do like that the points how
they're allocating the 0.6 it's always
harder to like
it's always easier to kind of be the
defender
um
and it and so they've kind of balanced
it whereas if you win as the defenders
you're not getting as many points
oh okay so we're defending uh anybody
else bring um
land mines because you can just straight
up land mine the yeah
i don't have landlords i'm gonna try to
get
some high ground i'm with jake oh we're
up in the top right here okay i'm gonna
land mine the um hostage over here
oh one's going the other way i see one
around the left right now
i'm with the two uh i'm with our two
blueberries here nope
that one
oh [ __ ] i got down he's right there i
put quite a few rounds in him though
here i'm coming who's gonna wilson
they grabbed a prisoner oh i see him
hold on lickable uh panda says is
groundwater in the beta it will be at
some point this weekend but it is oh
[ __ ] me yeah i saw that
fudge bucket
yeah and for what it's worth aaron is
playing on
ps4
oh i see what you're saying about the
gopro that's dope
that's why it looked i was like what is
this fov like what's going on here yeah
all over the shoulder kind of cool
oh thank you someone's inviting me
oh they just snap snag
grab the hostage okay okay so i got a
little mini tank thing that i don't want
to mess with uh wilson
sorry lickable panda ground war is in
the beta uh it will apparently be
playable this weekend it is just
currently not one of the modes that is
available
sorry so we need
we need to get to the extraction point i
uh killed one that was carrying the
hostage um okay where you're at the i'm
down i'm down
nice job
okay but they're still ahead in points
that's actually kind of cool
yeah it's because they extracted one
hostage yeah
okay that's clever
what was that because these modes always
just
that's a wilson you you call it as a
kill streak
oh gotcha
i'm gonna run the same play i'm gonna go
up to the right i'm yeah i'm gonna do
that too
okay so right hostage is undefended
right now that's where they went last
time maybe they'll go left uh we had
like we're gonna go left last time that
uh that i took out but three of them
went and some went right as well yeah
okay i feel like the right hostage is
gonna get snagged we're not defending
right at all
although maybe you can move around and
get them
yep
watch the guy on the right i see him i'm
flanking them i think they're going i
think they've got the right hostage yep
dang it that electricity thing is okay
he's down
another one here sneaking
through over here oh i can mark
i just marked
man that electric grenade stun grenade
really messed me up there
still over here
you just got me down i just if you prone
you can revive me
oh it's i think that's that's a random
that's a random
all right random good job
[Laughter]
did you see her just poke his head
around the corner just like oh hello
raphael lucas in the chat says anyone
can anyone buy me a ps5 for me please um
yeah i got you bro
we can't do that uh but um
am i am i able to plug uh my own channel
because i'm actually doing a charity
stream
giving away a ps4 very soon cool uh so
if you go to twitch.tv forward slash
great briton
g-r-e-a-t-b-r-i-t-o-m we're doing a
charity stream on the 25th of this month
and in order to help raise money we are
giving away a ps5
so if you don't have a ps5 yet that
might be
turning for that aaron you'll have to
you'll have to tune in we'll get you
upgraded
it's for the kids i'm all for it
uh okay i have the prisoner i got you i
got you covered kind of yeah i'm with
you
yep yep yep yep all right
don't run past that
i don't even know where he was i think
he's prone up top
i want to do it i don't see him anymore
uh i don't know if i can still revive
you oh yeah okay i can't
oh you get like one revive oh he's up
there in that corner you're good you're
good nice that's one
all right we should probably do a round
of revives before we uh
take the next one
there's somebody camping my body up in
the bridge area yeah in the corner
yeah
oh this
son of a geez where was that guy he's
not at the bridge
all right i'm coming to you behind me
there's three bodies right there
that's a pretty good strategy in this
game is you can either camp the hostage
or camp somebody's body like on the
other team
how many rounds do we get is one run
uh
i say we do let's do right
give the right a try let's go right okay
let's go right right not yeah yeah hard
right hard right hard right hard right
hard right
right almost off the map
that's right
along long lane
oh he's up there oh my
god got him
assist he's down gun is that dude you're
using get quick scoops
all right definitely someone in here we
got two down we should probably revive
our team
i got you covered on him kind of
driving
but by this point they've probably
started sweeping
the map
he's sweep right he's over here to the
right
got him i'm picking you up
thank you very much
probably camping bodies oh yeah he's
camping bodies those bodies are camped
and he's back over here on this side
is there anyone in here he got me in tow
i think we're good in here yeah behind
you
he's coming around
oh
[Music]
oh no no come on don't pick up anything
escort the prisons
vedic boyle says i don't know how to
apply for free open beta you don't have
to apply for the
open data that's available to everyone
you can just download it from the
playstation store or if you're waiting
for the xbox one from the xbox style
or
battle net i'm assuming on pc
i like this mode
yeah i do too yeah that was pretty neat
the point system is clever because these
rounds always just evolve into tdm but
with the point system you don't win
necessarily
just if it devolves into cem
yeah
all right what did we unlock here
unlock tree's been it's a little bit
slow i think they only have one rifle
unlocked so far you yeah i
was surprised they didn't have any more
at this point
no smg's unlocked yet
okay
13 16. i've got two assault rifles now
smg's unlock it
oh yeah that's pretty high pretty high
up there like 15 20 and
i'm stuck on a
loading page
just says waiting for relay
i eat all of these load screens like
take really a really long time yeah okay
let's give it a moment i dropped the
link for people for the charity stream
on the 25th next week uh you can also
follow me on twitter great britain it's
the it's uh the after everything after
the uh
the slash there um for more details on
timing and stuff um but it'll be a long
stream we'll probably play a bunch of
call of duty if anyone
and it'll probably be open for people so
people can jump in and play
um maybe these guys will want to come
play some mao but um
yeah so how are we feeling about it
how's everyone feeling about it's okay i
mean i i'm
i think i'm i'm more most excited to uh
to really mess with the guns a little
bit more you know get some get some
faster ads some some better recoil and
stuff like that but
i don't know it's nice um
i don't think i've ran into a map that i
don't like yet i mean i still have
preferences but it's i don't know it i
like it better than cold war i can say
that much um cold war i i just i don't
know like like with all respect to cold
war there was just something about it
about the multiplayer and the way that
like those maps felt it just was like a
little too arcadey
and i don't know so
what about you guys yeah again it's a
it's it's the two different crowds right
like there's your classic call of duty
crowd that likes the fast
you know short time to kill three lane
kind of stuff and i think cold war
really catered to that crowd yeah and
this is this is a sandbox game it's like
you know jay carter said he made a gun
that like didn't work too good and real
quick david cancel this because you got
kicked so i'm gonna send you an invite
to the party yeah no i'm i'm stuck in
this uh thing i'm just gonna reset the
uh
i'm gonna reset the game real quick
go for it
the sandbox i think is there like it's
really cool i already realized like
drill charges can just be used on
regular cover
there's a huge weapon customization
system lots of vehicles we're just sort
of scratching the surface here with the
6v6 modes uh we'll really see when
groundwork kicks in
hopefully later this weekend
lots of call of duty players though like
if you hate campers uh
i think jake and i both love taking out
campers as they like past time
this game is open
this game is very like open the maps are
very open so i think you will find
you will need to do that in this game oh
jake what are you thinking
uh i'm enjoying it quite a bit so far uh
all right i joined up tom
[Music]
i think so yeah yeah uh let's try the
um
the final mode that's available
currently knockout
um but yeah it's it's a bit too hard to
like get attached or too interested in a
beta because i know my progress is going
to get wiped
uh
yeah and like
yeah
so i don't know i i don't know i'm
really curious to dig into gunsmith once
um i have the game and once i am not
concerned about getting anything wiped
yeah um
seems good i i'm way more interested
also in uh like war zone 2.0 dmz mode um
sort of 6v6 because you know i i do like
how it feels but this is still 6v6 call
of duty which i've played at this point
[Laughter]
that that was definitely my feeling when
we were watching next is like all of the
modern monsters all the all the stuff
they were showing off for this i was
like oh that's cool and then they got to
the warzone 2.0 stuff and i was like oh
i'm so stoked for that because i haven't
played warzone pretty much since they
changed the caldera map like i have not
played that
um
and i'm really
really excited to get back into yeah
so this is like uh this is kind of like
the rescue one but it's a package in the
middle and i guess we both
like we're competing to take it yeah
rather than like
one second
oh you got it i didn't kill either of
those guys
spectator camera's hilarious
yeah i like it a lot
all right this guy's carrying us
let's go
[Music]
so you just take the drug money and and
run with it
make the money run
oh it's whoever's holding it i think it
is whoever's holding it at the end of
the round
uh
oh
sorry for mangling that says where's the
looking version aaron where did you find
that
okay so and you
yeah think
it jake found it it's actually one menu
deep
it's it's not
uh what was it under jake it was like
uh
let's see
i get controller
good for it vertical aim access then you
gotta click show more and then there's
an option to do it
all right everybody
everybody like i guess protect me i died
i was i was way behind i was looking at
the menus
tom you didn't do your job you're
supposed to protect me i was so far
behind i tried i was trying
i was just trying to get further
oh what
gentlemen i do not think we are
competitive people
no
[Laughter]
it was uh my and it was initially
confirmed watching the pros play
yesterday and it is being doubly
confirmed
don't revive me because i'm not going to
save you outcast
look at that
all thanks to us
not outcast at all he didn't do anything
they didn't do anything
there's like um if there's like a top
metagun i'm the kind of person who will
never use that gun i'll go try and find
something else that's like more
interesting
it's not fun to do
the most optimal thing ever
being a meta slave
yeah i hate that
that's that's when you're
destined was it uh
my my
i guess weapon with the other oh my god
i'm gonna punch something sorry what
i just got taken out right away by
someone prone
jesus
scared the hell out of me are we just
camping on this thing oh they're all
over here
they're they're all to the right of this
he's in the back corner
oh thank you outcast
ah someone from behind got me
oh no
nice
that was someone's uh someone had laid a
where's this dude nope where
dude outcast is on a 10 kill streak is
there anyone on your guys's bodies
um
i don't think
oh i think outcast died or no i switched
it just takes forever to switch players
holy [ __ ] can you
die my guy
so who's holding the whoever's holding
the bag wins yeah i don't know who has
the bag right now
oh yeah so like if you don't get them
then they win yeah this is so dumb
dude i like
engaged him on two or three different
times and he just like ate so many
bullets and just go around the corner it
was [ __ ] annoying my gameplay says
show us third person view so third
person mode is its own dedicated mode
and it is currently not available
but it should be at some point this
weekend what game mode would it be under
is it like a i think it's just like
around wordpress and tdm or oh yeah it's
like it's something like a modifier
i don't even want to stick my head out
on this corner
yeah they're going back left
oh
no they're coming around coming around
the mountain
oh no he's behind me oh my lord
oh leo
is sliding in the game
sliding in dolphin diamond
i just do things
thank you
okay we gotta go get the guy with the
bag before we go thank you
yeah you got about 45 seconds
oh he mind me
nice trick in the package
oh
my god shot once i wish i was the other
guy in the corner
[Music]
if we have the bag just don't update the
back we don't
oh okay
southcast
what the hell
oh my god
love been loving outcast that was a poor
judgment call on on his part there
he would he he should not have revived
me
oh she could like point at the guy you
wanted him to revive when you're on the
ground
not me not me
i'm not the guy i mean maybe that's what
proximity chat's for what's your buck
yeah
yeah that's a good point
i'm not the guy oh he's right here
nice time
try and grab it they're probably camping
that's right yeah i think grab it and
come back yeah yeah if we go up top here
here guard me up here we're gonna like
hide in the building yep
we're going upstairs
yep and
i'll watch this i'll watch the stall
i think it gave away my trophy system
okay
i'm out of mines right now so
they're shooting up up the stairs
oh there's another stack
i'll see if i can cover the other
staircase there's one more in that uh in
the tunnel
he's gonna have his buddy there's a guy
on on b reviving his buddy there's two
of them
oh this shield has come in handy
oh [ __ ]
hell yeah we got that we got that one
do it let's just do this all over again
that's how you can't
say you can't ladies and gentlemen
it makes me think of like oddball during
the halo that one halo map or everyone
just run up the tower
really taking me back to the original
warfare 2 with all that camping
this
whole alleyways sucks so gnarly
i don't mean that in a bad way it's just
it's it's rough to hold on to yeah
that that corners already covered
and they usually like to flank oh jesus
christ
i was not expecting that whole card
it's over there
grenade in here
i don't know why that guy did not shoot
us that was really good
oh i am dead right next to you david
okay
when it's safe on the other side of the
car
oh my [ __ ] god oh did you get shot
yeah i couldn't even see him dude he's
just like all this rubble
nice
in terms of time to kill if you start
taking shots you have a split second to
duck before you go down so i think it's
actually kind of a good balance if you
react fast enough
you can
you can kind of get away from it yeah
that feels about yeah dave um at the end
of this match could you like scoot your
camera over a bit because you're like
camera's covering up your um
like the hud the freaks yeah and stuff
yeah i got you
you can do that after this match for
sure
just a little scooty
we can do this i feel in my bones that
that we are going to turn this around
you dress i also feel in my bones i'm
going to eat my words
[Laughter]
outcast that dude that's what i was
doing earlier but yeah
totally not suspiciously
oh yeah that corner is okay now we're
looking at that i'm gonna mark the
corner
the corner sucks
okay i've down the guy that was holding
the bag
and i've picked it up i think okay goes
up go to the top top strap
we're only going against one person left
we should
take him out
i just ran into a bloke dummy uh for the
first time that's hilarious you bust
into a room and like this dummy just in
place right in front of you
this is called knockout you're not
it's like money
yeah interesting choice
all right team camping strats let's go
oh yeah that corner over there man
oh
dude stop picking up the gun oh i just
want to revive
there we go oh if you d if you have
contextual uh if you hold it'll reload
and not pick up
there's two settings
the setting that lets you
pick up more quickly you have to hold it
to reload
these outcasts is good
you gotta be holding the package in 10
seconds though
[Music]
[Laughter]
says sup david my king
oh hey there we go
here with the with the last minute dave
over here with the left and say it was
clutch
just using outcasts as a as a sacrifice
all right everybody annoy outcast and
follow
that person because they are way better
than us
and someone else in the chat was nice
and sad glad to see a street what
glad
you got the money
okay here go go go building
building strat
okay just be careful because there's
another room here okay yep i set up my
little thing uh we need we need people
to cover outside here
yeah there's one running
to your left i got the uav upright oh
there's only two left
yeah one of them is around the corner
outside this building
one here remember you can mark you can
mark
are the ones here
nice i told you
melted in my bones good job good job
oh that felt great
arms bones are right
my bones are never off
[Laughter]
see that i was mounted that was a
mountain kill
oh yeah all done all done outcast
out of that jumpy sliding [ __ ] just
sitting there mounted covering a lane
all right that was stressful
oh man
you found like the we found the the
house that you have hey devonta's in the
chat what's up bud hi devonta
yeah go back to work devante
what are you doing i know you don't i
edit the news i know you don't have time
to be in the chat right now
um
tom you're leader so you can just throw
us into whatever oh okay there we go oh
um yes let's do that okay jake i see you
going with an lmg there that's a that's
a brave move on 6v6
tried it it didn't work because i think
i've maxed out i've leveled up the
m4 about as much as i can so
you have to become a dolphin diving
shotgun bro
swan dive into the time of your life
no
the um the great thing about kale
streaks is i don't have to worry about
them because i'm never good enough to
use them so like
just don't have to worry about it at all
yeah
uh
the dark side of the forest s you can
revive people in regular multiplayer no
that was a special mode
we're going back to team deathmatch
yeah
yep
like the more i really do like the guns
yeah it definitely just takes time to
get into a groove i'm i'm enjoying my
time quite a bit
but it'll help play with the crew as
well i think yeah and outcast definitely
and outcasts for sure and outcast
is our cast still with us no with that
no yeah
that'd be pretty much
[Laughter]
all right jake i'm gonna i'm gonna try
what you tried with the lmg just i i
know this is a bad idea but you're gonna
do it on your switch
i'm i'm
just a k looking gun
this doorway over here is becoming like
the counter-strike
dusk doorway in my book it's just
oh two of them
eric lmg
you got it
i got two but then i got flanked it
worked out yeah
okay
um i've already found a couple of like
good climbing routes
which is again like it's a big infinity
war thing
a lot of their maps have these um places
oh come on
says how are you all liking the newly
tuned movement without slide cancelling
and added dolphin diving
how are we feeling about that dolphin
diving's hilarious
i don't know uh
i using dolphin
so far it hasn't become
therefore it hasn't become too big of a
problem uh in terms of slide cancelling
is that where
i think what you're saying is like
after all the streamers near where
they're just always like where did you
sprint slide
yeah the the like slide sprint slide the
cracked out hamster [ __ ]
you know what's interesting is what we
saw a lot in the stream yesterday was a
lot of the um
other pro streamers were like
i don't know what exactly they're doing
they're running and swapping weapons
constantly i think to try and gain some
kind of speed boost yeah i saw that too
but
we haven't seen like the
the sort of classic
sprint slide it's been open
print slide sprint's live we haven't
really seen that
yeah oh i have i have concerns about
dolphin diving
that's like just one of those things
that gets so easily exploitable after a
while when people start really doing it
a lot right
but we'll see no it's not too bad yet
but this is like the first day of the
beta so people haven't
gotten super good at it yet right
eight pedals says in the chat they just
need to slow the speed of the character
and promote a stamina bar to minimize
the bunny hopping in slides that would
be interesting
stamina bar so like you you technically
you do you have like a stamina bar
because you can only tax print for so
long
so it's
kind of that a little bit
um
[Music]
i don't know like
once once everybody gets their hands on
these things it usually it usually
develops a whole other life yeah the
beta
nice jake
we got a quad kill [ __ ] yeah
don't know how i did that but we gotta
kill street then
oh yeah we got some killstreaks oh yeah
let's start with the care package
we'll say that it does feel i i think
everything feels really good um
you always forget that when you strike
i got a c4 drone i don't see anything
wrong with strapping a c4 to a drone
how do i blow this up i don't know
that's the the battlefield jeep stuff
that uh i was talking about aaron it's
like
i saw one of those drones in the trailer
go straight into a helicopter all right
i got a stealth bomber and a care
package so let's uh
drop this thing right dead center
there's a guy in a building right over
you jake
yeah oh i switched my gun to semi when i
was
uploading
there are a lot of routes on this map
it's three lane but there's like a lot
of ways through the lanes which is kind
of cool yeah i think this is my favorite
map in the beta
so
i'm far this ak as well
also also the person who asked that like
what do you prefer
what kind of movement do you prefer it
sounds it sound like more slow with a
stamina bar
changing back
the drill charge is more versatile than
a you know first thought
yeah
you can use it on just regular cover
i am with you
i guess the real question with movement
system in this game though is like how
it plays on a really big hat
like when you can really
move long distances
jake did you know so is it there's other
weapons like really capped in the beta
you can only get a couple unlocked
i i'm not sure i'm level
nine or so and i feel like i hardly have
anything
but it looks like the max level is 30
when i was looking at progression at
least for the beta for the beta yeah
yeah
like i imagine all the weapons that are
there you can unlock because that seems
like a pretty small group of weapons
like if that was all the weapons that'd
be pretty uh disappointing
ah damn
you're gonna recognize this kill cam
from the last round
same spot
that's so funny
hey do what you got to do
hey that guy yeah that got the dub right
so there you go
same spot mounted in the exact same lane
yeah elaine's nasty
let's see if the game whoops i think
i've been i think i've been muted for a
while
[Laughter]
uh someone in the chat darkseid the four
says uh what does what do we think the
best movement is
the go-to gun uh i've been playing with
the m4 which is the default what else
have
you guys been messing around with
uh i've been doing the m4 although i
just used the um
kostav 70 74u which did me pretty well
nice nice nice uh lotus in tom
yeah it's it's it's doing the thing oh
gotcha it just didn't appear on my
screen
yes
also some of these guns don't have any
levels you can
level up really gross as is the hardcore
mode in the beta there is no hardcore
mode at the moment they're going to be
swapping out modes over the weekend
currently the three modes are
quick play which includes tdm and
domination there is a rescue
the hostage mode that is very like
rainbow six siege which i think after
domination i kind of want to go back to
because i enjoyed that and then there
was knockout which is where you hold the
bag
team that's holding the bag at the end
of the game wins
movement's feeling good i feel like uh
movement's feeling good
hostage rescue mode for people who are
you know joining us
now
a lot more clever than
um some other house of rescue modes in
the past because it's a point system so
you don't necessarily win just by
killing the entire other team
if they extract the hostage and then you
kill them they can still i think get
more points than you
it's
we got the classic uh the foundry map
again
oh there's a hole uh underneath
underground around here
so you can spot which is like
enemies
you have me if you can spot him in a
game
someone's name is not a football fan
which is pretty funny
you know he's a football fan
you know he's got a he's got a bad
relationship with it though yeah
yeah
he's like a giants fan
you all need to do laundry i'm working
uh laundry machines oh good yes
not on that one map on the the janitor
map oh yeah tom tom really likes janet
or fightmap i love janitor maps dude i'm
not even ashamed
[Music]
yes
um i've been doing it not intentionally
so i don't really know
how
oh yeah there are some laundry machines
on the roof
[Music]
[Music]
i'm on see
oh
i got him with the flash let's go son
uh someone's going to be right now
i got the guy who's coming around to see
one of them looks like there might be
another i'll back you up
yeah so i'm noticing some of these guns
in the beta don't you can't level up um
so if you are trying to progress these
guns i would make sure that they
actually have levels like that ak i was
using as good as it was i couldn't level
up
yeah okay
upstairs at c
[Music]
i definitely had some rubber banding
there just let him keep spawning
oh what it's just in the corner let's
see
they are taken b
yep
see but
oh he's up on the roof god damn it i
don't care oh they're gonna they're
gonna take me again
damn
i think i finally got the guy at sea
okay
again
if you are an xfinity customer i can't
believe we're doing like a free xfinity
ad right now if you're an xfinity
customer you can get a free code um
i'm sure of the call of duty like social
channels giving away some streamers will
probably be giving them away
um
but
the the basic way to gain access this
weekend
yes
all right i'm taking b we're getting it
yes
[Music]
uh they are by sea now
oh i ran right into a grenade like an
idiot
that [ __ ] guy on the building every
time on c
yeah yeah dude
it's like just take the objective don't
just
uh
[Music]
a nice little grenade there
all right snagging because
yeah i killed the guy who was at sea
there's another one right here
yeah that's interesting
uh i am at a and no one is noticing me
right now so i'm just sure
this guy looking from behind on b from c
to b
yep yep yep
oh this is how you get the second story
that is interesting i love it what the
[ __ ] infinity wars
designs there's a dude just
chilling on the window they love that
building at sea that's really annoying i
know
the area
all right oh
i cleared beach
they're all over here all of them are
over here
flash uh the flash animation is more
advanced
sucks to be you
get up there you suck
oh i really hate that
[Applause]
grab and see
yeah we should take moving
[Music]
double kill do for the kill there's a
guy looping around
he always is
it's probably the same damn yeah he's
damn dude
sorry
scared me
oh someone's on b i just popped
yeah but they got a trophy in there uh
that might be my trophy
angry ginger and i are on a
we're taking c we should just move
[Music]
somebody asked this earlier and i just
thought you you can revive we are tied
yeah but we got two at least not for
long though come on we got this we got
this
let's just let's just make sure we we
can lock down b yeah
here i'm going to reset it
looking around looping around
oh yeah
if we need it someone is near there
though so we might need to reinforce it
my ps5 like
[Music]
oh god a guy behind me [ __ ] no someone
killed him all right
we almost got it
nice nice nice we can get b i'm throwing
a trophy
oh nice okay we got him though nice job
good game
that was that was
got a little yeah it got pretty tight at
the end there but
good place
this [ __ ] on the god damn
all the time oh there was that one guys
just harassing the entire match
yeah
just dug into a couple of different
buildings and then just wouldn't even
take objectives yeah
um
do you guys want to give the prisoner
we're only going for another 15 right is
that correct
um
i think i mean you know if you guys have
projects you have to give back to you're
fine but i think based on
concurrence we could probably go for a
little longer i'll uh i can go for
longer yeah yeah i'll ask uh i'll show
lucante how they're feeling but usually
you know it seems like we got a strong
stream going got a lot of people in chat
that are excited to see more so
we'll just keep the party going people
good lord every time it kicks me out of
the weapons menu
it's it's annoying isn't it isn't it
god
[Laughter]
all right let's see what chat is saying
uh they're all arguing over exclusives
what's coming uh this uh
never change chat
[Laughter]
honestly from software is one of the
best steps here we go let's get into
some elden ring right now
i love chat dude that's so funny
says one of the adding ground war to the
beta we don't know i think like
usually their social channels will say
like this is what's coming up right i
feel like that happened in pre a
previous year but basically ground war
at some point this weekend
if yeah if i was if i was to take a bet
they don't want to probably launch
grandma without enough people so maybe
tomorrow or sunday yeah yeah when does
it go open it goes from close to open
after a day or two so probably by sunday
they would have grown more in there if i
had to guess yeah
makes sense
groundwater's fun man so i've played i
actually had a chance to play around
more um it's um
much bigger
and a lot of it like every building you
can get inside of every building it is
just tons of interior space in those
maps which is cool
then the underwater components to it
it's very like it's the most battlefield
that they've really done at this point
all right
back on the drug map
okay so we gotta play it smart all right
we've been kind of laughing about
exclusivity because
you know with microsoft trying to buy
call of duty and then sony is kind of
throwing a legal fit over it but oh my
god like sony's entire stretch is always
based on exclusivity including this game
yeah the fact that
this bait is on playstation is funny to
me
i know they're their deals still going
so it makes sense but it's just like
with everything going on they they're
complaining too they're like oh this
isn't good for the game microsoft like
why are you doing this oh hey guys uh
play on playstation first like come on
come
on
you guys want to see
samurai skin which doesn't make sense at
all
oh we just
yeah we just kind of rocked them i
didn't do anything
i literally was looking at the chat i
didn't move yeah i didn't i didn't do
anything at all a bunch of them quit
that's right okay
that's unfair
it's us from several matches ago
there you go
if david's playing on ps5 and he has 120
hertz set it should be at 120 frames a
second but his capture won't be showing
it yeah yeah no matter what the stream's
gonna be
yeah the stream is gonna be 16.
how many of them are there they must
have gone right there's three of them
well two behind you
um they're on the left
ground jake
[Music]
well done david you got them talking
about elden ring now
[Laughter]
just feed them breadcrumbs
oh damn he took out two of us
i didn't even know he was he was
hovering around there
yeah
oh okay oh no
i pushed hard i put a bad sight on this
oh no pickle rick is afk
is it just him it's just him it is just
him
oh no he's he's back he's back it's all
part of his plan
[Laughter]
[Music]
amazing amazing
that's pretty funny
oh my god i have not seen that yet i
wonder if it's a ps4 thing
oh maybe
that dude got so
rocked
center lane is a big sniper lane
looks like we're back to like a 6v5
altadool says in the chat this may let
you customize your guns a lot yes there
is gun customization but we don't think
there are a ton of
weapons available
just because progression is very limited
yeah uh in the beta so we're not really
unlocking a ton of weapons but yes there
is
the gunsmith
also nothing
is i don't think things are going to
carry over for like progress wise uh
there's that as well no
i saved the hostage by shooting them
with an lmg about 50 or so here we get
to watch it
there you go
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh cure hazy says yeah exactly uh does
this game have spec ops um
game does yeah full game will yeah
the game will have uh two players back
up so it's not gonna be
all right they've learned their lesson
no one's going center
i i gave you some backup bullets there
i just saw someone hang uh hang and do
their thing enemy uav
nf1 says what's the new game modes aaron
you probably
uh uh what are the new this is a new
game mode this is yeah yeah all these
competitive modes are now
yeah the ones that we've just been
playing now are hostage rescue where you
ski one or two hostages but it's points
based so if you get
you can still
kill the other team
and then there's like this like grab the
bag
which they call something weird or
whoever's holding them
yeah yeah knockout grab the drug money
and run
whoever's holding the drug money at the
end
there's also an invasion which we don't
have yet we might over the weekend
though but that's like the big team
battle with a.i
uh mode
you call that okay so i finally
understood what you were trying to say
like in the script they were saying it
was the
which means they were just trying to say
it's the grindy map of brown when you
want to go behind your guns
and that's against ai
snipes
that's the ones in the in the beta but
like if you're talking about like
you're talking about overall the one
that the one that many of us are really
excited for
is the um
battle maps because battle maps now
encompass ground war so brown war is
just one
mode in battle maps there's going to be
a whole bunch of modes now and instead
of just groundwork
oh they're all right here on top of me i
don't even want to open this door
i'm gonna yeah i'm gonna revive
yeah here we go
no that's jake sorry thank you yeah
oh is that the same
same guy i didn't think he'd still be
there oh you dead dead now i can't okay
so you got one revive
like each person can only be revived
once
yeah if you die a second time it's it's
lights out gotcha gotcha
but there's no limit on how many people
you could revive at one time though
right like you could revive a whole team
if you have yes i think so yeah yeah
[Laughter]
they
and gotcha at the in the 11th hour
ah that sucks
okay aaron all right
just be someone who's good at playing
this game oh is that me oh sh all right
here we go if it'd be good to play in
this game
right here
we got one
i'm right i where my body is in that
rescue is it's right by the exchange
yeah yeah is there is there anyone on
youtube tom or cruise missile where is
it oh lord oh look
there was oh he's looking at there he's
behind the car yeah he's like in our
spawn behind the car
oh god what is that
oh you got him nice
[Laughter]
well done that's pretty funny that was
pretty funny i i saw that kill came and
i was like oh my god are they trying to
like disintegrate my body now like it's
just insult to injury
oh it's a little bit dirty that there's
killstreaks
that it is pretty messed up and i mean i
don't know i feel like there should be a
penalty for
like obliterating your hostage with that
as collateral
yeah exactly exactly
saw somebody uh do the ledge
pledge
the legend
yeah you know i'm gonna do it right here
on this wall
i've only ever done it accidentally like
i'm not intending to do it at all i
don't know how to pull my oh because i
don't have a pistol that's why
um
yeah oh someone did a finisher on me oh
my god dude finish yourself
[Music]
uh are you clear
i don't know who's who
the revival is dead i'm gonna grab the
person behind cover
picking up weapons again okay
oh i'm so dead
oh
oh dude that guy did not
see
us that was funny
all right um
okay
hold on hold on
the the enemy ran right by me while i
was uh reviving
uh aaron and then he was just i guess
focused on the hostages
well i i can't tell i can't tell who's
who like there's there's no indicator
which is which is gnarly like yeah it's
really tough when someone's like right
in front of you i got one more game in
me and then i gotta go for sure
well then you get to pick what what game
mode do you want to try
yeah
uh
i mean i'm
fine with just regular domination or
it's quick play right so yeah quickly
whatever let's do quick play oh actually
i can filter i can filter out
um
i make it just domination yeah let's do
that hell yeah
you're dom
yep
[Laughter]
it's a friday all right it's a friday
it's a friday
so when we were playing domination
two rounds ago three rounds ago uh the
revive button did come up in just a
regular round i think if you get there
fast enough
you actually can revive somebody or
maybe
it might have been me because i had a
perk i had a second chance type perk or
second win or whatever
last time last stand thank you yeah last
night baby so that's that's probably
what it was i might have been in the
last stand animation and it gave you
guys like
an option to revive me or something that
might have been what you were seeing
that would make sense yeah oh yeah so
you were out you were like a
like secondary out yeah yeah yeah
basically so in in domination i was like
down and i had the option to like self
revive um i didn't have a pistol though
so i couldn't like shoot anyone i just
like was laying down there but it was
nice people weren't expecting it there
were times where i was able to revive
myself and
you know
just cap people basically
have we done this map on domination i
don't think so
no
i'm going to head to a
oh you know what i think we have because
i've yeah i recognize b because of b
oh yeah
we've lost all the things let's pick one
hey
i got shot
i have it set for single but it fires
auto and then when i have it set for
auto it fires single oh that does seem
like a bug that's annoying
you have to like pre-fire to double
check what you're on
david you just exploded so hard i did i
did you had a
front view of it oh i just ran by an
enemy too
oh god this is not my ground
it's still early turn this around
they're all in a's if it takes you right
now yeah we just grabbed it
all of them are on a we'll probably i'll
just meet the middle now yeah maybe
oh it's definitely grenades bam because
they
they love that
some folks are saying the motion blur
looks a little gross i think it's
adjustable you can turn it off yeah yeah
oh i turn that i turned that [ __ ]
right off i'm kind of used to it from
2019 so i kept it on but i understand
uh people don't like it
no david you're not allowed to
understand other people's preferences
okay
the enemy controls two objectives few
things that will make your games it's
your way or the highway all right
someone said uh who cares about
battlefield 2042 i do
i do no no battlefield slander here i'm
probably the only person that still
plays it
there's another game i still play but
i'm afraid to tell people if everyone's
just going to go why
kayla
no um
destiny
yes but uh what was supposed to be the
destiny killer that that died out
oh
i have no
idea it was super high you play it
it's uh
anthem yes
no
yeah i'm not playing it still i still i
still play anthem every now and again
can you even play it anymore well i mean
yeah there's like only like three people
it's like the same three people that
play that one strike
and like i don't know it's it's pretty
funny
but i just i don't know sometimes when i
want to like if i want to test out like
a new monitor or like a new graphics
card i'll just boot that baby up in 4k
and fly okay fair enough it's a
beautiful looking game yeah
but yeah it does suck and it makes me
sad because
i i i honestly gotta say in all of the
possible universes
holy cow wow
hey we got people we got people
enchanting anthem that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm talking about
you understand we got some and drop
anthem in the chat for all and all those
anthem lovers out there someone said to
be honest the chat is all over the place
this
[Laughter]
i love it it's friday
this is our this is what we're going to
say from now on
friday
hell yeah
maddox porter all these people in the
chat i really miss anthem
that's what i was saying
we should do that so you want to get
into this game series but for anthem
even even though it's dead so you want
to play anthem again
that would be a good video idea david
like revisiting anthem like what is it
like now
yeah it could be fun
right in the middle
all right we're in the death zone known
as b all right we got b and c
we can turn this around yeah 80 points
[Music]
cyberpunk is good now
uh i don't know about that
but it's
playable
i don't know i feel like it's it's
fundamentally like not the game that
they promised and like
really like
super fun to play yeah but
i think the world is cool i think that's
the thing you go for
the world and the world's like a
character yeah
up
damn smoke
also reloading oh a guy on the balcony
oh god
i shoot one
i'm gonna go
reloading
uh
the
there's like five on c right now or a
sorry
yeah i'm on b
as well
diving that was a question
people bringing up uh edge runners being
very good in the new netflix show and i
haven't checked it out yet have any of
you nope watch the new cyberpunk anime
very excited to watch it but i'm in the
middle of a breaking battery watch so
it's on hold
two objectives
yeah this gun's broken but like it's
kind of cool it's kind of fun i like it
yeah i'm definitely going to give
headroom as a shot especially because
it's a trigger you talking about your 8k
no it's uh it's the ftc
right
it's not like bugged in a good way it's
just kind of like awkward
it's
objective
fun
we're taking alpha
jock charges get it
uh building space or keeping somebody
from pushing you if you're weak
[Music]
i'm gonna move to see you there
if you see someone down trying to self
revive you can finish him
that's what happened
oh behind me
oh my god
oh my god
trying to revive you
got punched to death
i like moving in this game i just
escaped
like change the level so you can keep
them but just have it like
especially with like
single fire guns where it's like i gotta
pull the trigger each time that's a
little
yeah you're like you're like fighting
the trigger basically
good luck on the rest of the stream
thank you sir
i'm playing with you man and i'll talk
to you all later bye
so i just shot through some like car
windows we're gonna think about physics
between the two games and it's
definitely way better like yeah the
windows shatter and stuff that's cool
hell yeah
notice on the stream yesterday oh
playlist update available the playlist
update will now be downloaded
how interesting
so are we getting new modes right now
that would be wild
they're just waiting for jake to leave
maybe
yeah they were like oh jake's gone now
now we'll update
now here's yeah now here's here's the
other modes
here's more content for y'all
so partied up
uh yeah we should be
yeah yeah i accidentally backed out the
wrong
thing
i've been mostly just working on one
weapon that had a lot of customization
up front uh doesn't seem like you can
unlock
much customization for some of these
other weapons i don't know if it's just
the beta or what's going on there
um you are i think david you're the
party leader again i'm the leader okay
um looks like jake's actually still in
here let me
i'm actually gonna change some gun stuff
i can't i can't boot i'm here i'm just
going to leave the party and then you
guys can rejoin on me again
yes that's good
got m16
don't know when you want me
which
perk package had
um
you guys joined that stuff revive
uh i am trying to
i'm just [ __ ] invite you
david did you make the perk package that
had self revive yes i did it was a
custom thing for the custom loadout
all right i sent you guys game invites
there you go
hell yeah all right
nice
and perk packages so
[Music]
we want
a custom perk package
this is not like letting me like
customize the gun for some reason
oh okay i think
you can get there in time for
self-revive
and so this one has a that that laundry
map building has a lot more to it than
we thought um on the right side it's a
basement and an upper floor you have to
like climb to
whoa
all right
we got uh
hang on i gotta
change some settings we got people in
the chat trying to grief me by
sending me messages give me a sec
oh in the game chat mm-hmm yeah i'm just
gonna do privacy settings
oh i have the gun that is the wrong
yep
there we go
i have the jake the jake gun
where the
single and and uh burst fire swaps yeah
yeah
is there another team here
yeah chad you can all uh blast that dude
that was some some scummy [ __ ]
oh was someone doing something in the
game chat and uh uh well like yeah yeah
and no not in stream chat in in like the
actual playstation like they just sent
me a message that would pop up and then
deleted the uh the group like an
absolute coward
that's all right i uh ended up turning
off the uh
the comms there so
no more of that
oh someone was
someone was uh uh
all camped out in the corner there right
around on b
i'm still gonna be using like domination
callouts even though yeah
now because that's just like the easiest
way for me to uh
gauge although it's nice that like as
you're going through places you've got
um spots like the actual names like
training course north street but it's
just hard to remember at all i feel like
you know what i mean
and this map it's very easy to remember
where the spots are i feel yeah i feel
like half the time people just like make
their own call-outs anyway like laundry
room you know what i mean
like i'd rather refer to something as a
laundromat as opposed to like operations
building or whatever
interesting so i'm looking through some
of the other things you get out of this
field upgrades this portable radar i
don't know what that is
portable
decoy all right david i got to drop the
inflatable decoy near you because it is
so dumb it's going to be like the joke
of this entire game but like yeah
on the internet kind of way where are
you at
um i'm over i'm over by b right now
i can't believe
this decoy is
changing i don't think it has any like
real value but it's just
kind of stupid and fun yeah
oh
oh so you just pop up
that's hilarious
apparently that decoy will swim
oh if you throw it in the water
yeah if you throw in the water it'll
pretend to swim
damn
the recoil is something you definitely
have to get used to
i don't know if it's the um
visual recoil because it seems like it's
not too bad in terms of
going
the gun i'm using right now when it's in
the semi
got a uav
thank you
freaking garbage truck is outside my
house and it like threw off my headset
i was like what
what have you noticed but zoom zoom has
gotten really good at tuning out
come on somebody i just really want
somebody to take the bait here
oh come on let me run in here take the
bait
okay somebody fly
me up
not fool the guy at all
nutella if you have the pre-order you
should be able to play the uh the beta
on ps4 we've got aaron here actually
playing on ps4 pro
yeah it's not just playstation 5 it's
playstation 4 as well
you have to be careful when you redeem
your codes because they're specific
there we go
that might be the issue then
you uh redeemed it for the ps5 you might
be out of luck
that
would suck if that is what
and i know on like playstation like with
ps5 like down like downloading the right
game and like making sure that is the
correct version
yeah is a pain so
that's what happened
it was so funny when they were
when it was the lead up to the next gen
consoles and xbox was like we have smart
delivery
where it knows the console you're on it
downloads the correct version and we're
all like yeah so like of course that's
how it works and then like we got our
hands on the playstation
that's why smart delivery is so smart
yeah i 100 agree
yeah for anyone looking for a code we've
mentioned it before but for new people
in the chat if you are an xfinity
customer uh you can get a free you can
play right now
um
there's a rewards page i guess your
account page
requested airstrikes
therefore it is um feels like it has a
little bit more recoil
because i think um over time 2019
branded a little bit
more well it depends if you're talking
about war zone where like regular 2019
because regular 2019 still feels super
good this feels as good as regular 2019
to me and
i can't quite put a finger on exactly
what it is
even a little bit better in the way i
think the animations are sort of
displaying what's happening
and jake was already able to build a bad
gun which i actually think is a really
good sign that it's a sandbox that
really lets you mess around
and
build things that are kind of crazy
which is fun like pranking guns and
things like that
so so far i like it a lot um if you are
like a cold war fan and you really like
sort of the
sort of the laser gun styles of
traditional call of duty
then again i think this might not be
your
your year because there are two call of
duty audiences
and this is the like milsim audiences
kind of call of duty here
and like
old work to me felt a little bit
do i need to buy vault edition to play
war zone 2 um there is no war zone 2
i think at least apparently
but when it launches it will be free to
play oh we're going to steal this guy's
loadout oh nope he killed me instead i
thought he was dead warzone 2 is also
like the the last war zone it's free uh
but it is also separate so you're
it's interesting you know like i can see
what people
i haven't seen like a lot of like people
upset about it but
because i think they are two different
styles of games and it's actually
probably better to have the war zone for
the the fast crowd in the war zone for
the slower
milsim crowd yeah but
i respect that people might not be happy
that their stuff they spent money on
isn't coming with them but at the same
time like
really didn't want war zone 2 to launch
with godzilla skins and
just all the silly clown robbers and
things that were in the last game right
right
those things are eventually going to
come back in because they got to make
those uh they got to make those uh
you know those
you know cross-promotional rev deals
there are two things that i can promise
you about virtually every call of duty
and cheater game it is one there will
always be a crossbow by dlc3
and two
[Laughter]
you will get silly clown skins at some
point
all the cool kids at the crossfit
yeah
you're gonna love it
every time there's just always a
crossbow i i don't know why
like every time
and it's usually by dlc3 that they just
give up and put it in crossbow
this is new
i don't think we play this map yet
oh really
didn't play this map this is new
one
what was the name of it
uh i
took it back it was like
i'm down or hotelier
yeah this is definitely new
something that's always frustrating
about call of duty maps is they are
places that i would want
did a remake of what was like hollywood
hills or something like that
oh yeah that happens
this is dope
executing the objective charlie
that's us uh which one
aaron what's what's the uh the mansion
map that was in cold war but it's also
been in like every a bunch of other call
of duty games
they're over here
oh oh single fire god damn it
yeah heads up anyone rocking uh i figure
what the name of this gun is
single fire mode and semi-auto
so you start off on single fire in it
but it looks like it's full auto right
yeah that's what jake was uh was dealing
with yep so just just be careful anyone
that's playing the beta
recon seems like it's a
a universal
game runs in 120 hertz on ps5 for series
x the stream currently is in 60
because that's just how streaming works
uh
when you walk into different areas it
tells you so i'm in north one chandelier
look at the top of your screen yeah yeah
yeah
i'm gonna do that
all that you were talking about uh yeah
yeah exactly
i'm at the bar
check-in things like that
it's really
it's really funny like how quickly you
can get i think that's something that's
something that every call of duty game
regardless of how you feel about their
maps like they become memorable
despite
a couple of hours i feel very familiar
with the other ones already yeah yeah
oh yeah this is a giant
oh my god
the enemy has captured two objectives
move to secure
enemy is securing charlie
eric brown says is better for ps5 yet or
no
but be careful if you're redeeming your
beta code if you get one uh to redeem it
sounds like you can accidentally
redeem if you have ps4 you can
accidentally redeem ps4
lord lord says beta crashing a lot of
people's game yeah dave you're having
issues at the start right yeah
yeah yeah i mean it might happen once in
a blue moon but usually just like a
reset
um fixes it up you know what i mean
so far it's been very stable
hello right i'm just gonna stay on the
beat
i'm not i'm not afraid to say it oh well
never mind
were you gonna say you're just gonna
camp or something yeah
[Laughter]
that's timing that's why you never say
you're going to camp yeah
it's very hard to see sometimes
there's someone camping in the bank area
see
yeah
okay they ran down that hallway
oh my god
though these maps these are corn maps
aren't as small as i thought they were
going to be they kind of just grabbed
them oh they're quite quite large
actually this one
also from like a verticality style
ali is asking if uh if i think my
scope's getting in the way absolutely
dude the scope is kind of annoying i'm
not gonna lie
you can
you know you can't do it you can't do it
until you die but you can swap
some attachments
okay operation try and fool one person
with a demon
oh
an ammo pretty quick yeah
i guess i'll pick this gun
yeah that's one thing i hate about some
of the maps is like it just makes some
of those like offensive
perks
picked
up yes
engage exclusive i'm surprised nokia
hasn't tried to come back with that
because i feel like there are so many
companies that come have come back
including nokia with like
early 2000s nostalgia plays and they
feel like the engage is prime for uh
like bespoke like re-release
champagne
getting purses and
yeah this map is very
[Music]
on the walls
i feel like it would be a thing where
there'd be a ton of buzz online but when
it actually came to practice
not a lot of people would actually buy
it
everyone would talk a big game about
engage but
i feel like it would just get beamed
like that was the thing with the razor
came back and they were like yeah we're
making a folding phone it's the motorola
like
the fact that that even like flopped
like i feel like that was the one like
kind of gimmicky comeback phone that
actually had potential
and like still no one wanted it yeah
oh whoops did not mean to report
a player
because you only have 15 shots with it
um but they
have obviously not like
correctly like
indicated that
come back
all right operation fool one person
oh we oh interesting mission failed
return
uh what say you lads one more
uh yeah sounds about right
thank you everyone so much for tuning in
of course remember you know youtube
we've got a ton of other modern warfare
content coming out
so make sure to keep your eyes on
the prize
and yeah if anyone cares to join me next
sunday for a little charity stream for
the kids
we're going to be giving away a ps5
link is in the chat
um oh dave you're the party leader here
perfect i think it's auto
searching okay cool
should we like
last questions
yeah what's uh what's some last
questions here
people talking about the engage
that this one
squarely are you aaron johnny675 says we
need the pink bunny skins
you know it'll get there eventually it
always does yeah
we'll enjoy the first few months
yes
first of all
the wildest thing they had in the
original war zone
was like the trash skin which was
actually kind of cool
and then they slowly started heading
towards
really silly stuff by like cold war
the trash um ghillie suit i think i
remember that oh man that sucks psvr
games are not compatible with psvr2
it sucks
i can't really split that market
um
smg's seem to be pretty late in the
unlocked tree for some reason
maybe they're holding them for later in
the beta
i already got some uh
i like crash dummy charm which is kind
of funny
oh this gun also has the uh
also has the uh
the bug
oh wait what no i thought i okay
i i guess it didn't actually swap out
the gun
oh okay
no something that might
something might confuse people a little
bit who are watching
is the color palette is a little bit
cleaner
um
it kind of looks a little bit visually i
i could see how people would think it
looks a little bit more like
cold war
looking yeah
some of the maps are like
very sweet
it was the weirdest
grenade
from
i think our vanguard tried to please
both call of duty crowds and just
being adequate but not really like
special to either audience this means
way more into the modern warfare
audience yeah yeah
yeah i noticed that i was messing around
some people said everything was too
quiet so i raised it up and now i guess
the game audio is too loud so i
kept you guys the same but lowered the
the game audio
okay cool
the darth shikha who's the british guy
in the game swap team that's me tom
i do game spot news
if you guys watch gamespot news on
youtube.com
youtube.com there you go
it's right here we're right here you
just have to click that subscribe button
if you're not already subscribed hashtag
gamespot hashtag news hashtag
uh the great briton
um
and if you guys like the sound of my
voice you can come
join me for a charity stream as well on
my own channel
uh next sunday and we'll be giving away
a ps5 i'll drop the link in the chat
yes please do subscribe to
youtube.com
gamespot we will have a ton
of modern warfare 2 content coming out
over the next
few weeks and months here ali i'll show
you the dolphin dive right now
sprint
and then
wow
hey and i gotta kill after dolphin
diving there you go
oh it's just for you up about to get
oh my god it's interesting um you know
tom
was mentioning coverage of this game so
every
people feel about it but everything's
staggered this time so if you
pre-ordered it you get to play the
campaign like a week ahead
it's kind of cool because you always
want to just play the campaign
without like multiplayer like calling me
yeah
like a siren song
you don't want to feel like you're
getting left behind
right right
it's hard to want to play single player
so that gives you that option then
warzone couple weeks later
then
they haven't quite said yet but later on
raids
are going to happen
i appreciate that sounds like tarkov
sounds a little tarkovish yeah it's
probably going to be very talkative
which is a game that i haven't played at
all because
it always felt so like
um
like
hardcore you know and i feel like i'm
excited for it to
setting
did you guys ever mess around with taco
a little bit it wasn't for me
it's a very like
very punishing but rewarding game
do you you know if you sort it out
i just didn't like the walk out for that
reason i didn't like the lockout like
you know if you die as a scab or
whatever and then you can't play for
another like 30 minutes so that just
bothered me
it makes sense it feels like free to
play but not when i dropped 45 bucks for
it
right like i think the original pitch
for it
and like i think what the desert
originally told us about it was
basically like battle royale in a
straight line
kind of means that most people are going
to die and you lose all of your gear
each time
it initially seemed like it was designed
just to bleed all your gear and
eventually make you have to like buy
things
they came in with the scaf system later
on so you can still farm
gear
so yeah i don't know if you
you think that's interesting
uh yes the last question we will answer
is yes there is an ffv slider
yeah just it's the same same level of uh
changing the field of view as the
previous couple of games have been yeah
all right well we didn't end on a high
note but we had some great matches i
feel during yeah no we did we did and it
was it was a lot of fun too it was nice
to uh
to pop in you know
caught his back man it feels great
it doesn't thing that
just killed me was super interesting
that was a drill charge so it's an
anti-camping device like if you're in a
room um
that's cool yeah sorry i'm getting
fascinated by some of the gear in this
game
no man i mean it's it's it's sick and i
mean we're gonna we're probably gonna be
doing a lot for gamespot as well on on
cod especially you and me aaron with
like
messing with uh the guns maybe doing
some myth busting
just uh having a ball you know so
as uh tom mentioned to make sure you
guys subscribe to the channel you know
check out our daily news videos that he
does check us out check out the uh the
shooter videos and all the shooter
coverage that aaron and i are going to
be doing in the coming weeks uh it's
probably going to be it for us but for
those of you who joined us
uh
thank you guys so much it was a lot of
fun what a great way to spend a friday
morning and afternoon yeah
yeah yeah we did play for quite a while
it's been yeah it's it's we did play
very well and it was it was uh
definitely a blast
so that's gonna be it for us uh we'll
see you guys on the next live stream
take care y'all
have a good one guys
you